this was the hersan regional Art Museum
before Russia's Invasion a top tourist
attraction home to one of Ukraine's
largest art collections 14 000 pieces
some centuries old
but today the Museum's walls are bare
this museum is like the Louvre of
Ukraine says its director we have
nothing left they stole everything the
city of her son was occupied by Russian
forces for eight months until it was
liberated by Ukraine in November but
before the Russians left they looted
the Art Museum's deputy director says
staff moved most of the artifacts and
artwork down here to the basement for
safe keeping but one month before the
Russian Retreat a group of soldiers
arrived
they were accompanied by representatives
from the Russian Ministry of culture she
says they knew what they were doing she
says the Russians spent three days
prying the paintings out of their frames
and loading them into these trucks they
left almost nothing behind Ukrainian
officials and Museum staff say this
wasn't the work of a handful of Russian
soldiers who were simply looking to loot
some high-priced paintings but rather
they say it's part of a broader campaign
by the Russians to destroy Ukrainian
Heritage and culture Ukraine says
Russian forces have looted tens of
thousands of pieces from dozens of
museums and cultural institutions the
sheer scale of the art Heist drawing
comparisons to the Nazis in the Second
World War
and their plundered treasure includes
more than art
buried beneath this 18th century
Cathedral a crypt containing the tomb of
Russian prince yagiri potemkin so he was
buried here for more than 200 years the
founder of the city of her son lay here
for two centuries until last October
the Russian soldiers came and asked for
a tour the priest says then they
returned in the evening and told me to
open the Crypt he says the Russians
removed potemkin's bones in a cloth bag
and took them away
the Russians said they were taking the
remains to protect them because they
said the ukrainians were planning to
bomb the church he says but after they
fled it was the Russian army that turned
their big guns on her son
the priest showed us where the Russian
shelling hit in the yard outside the
cathedral the explosion shattered
windows and toppled the chandelier but
fortunately no one was hurt the
whereabouts of potemkin's bones are
unknown but some of the stolen artwork
has apparently turned up in
russian-occupied Crimea
these objects are proof of our Ukrainian
identity and history she says they're
trying to steal our heritage they want
to totally destroy it
but if that was indeed Russia's goal it
appears to be backfiring across Ukraine
Russian monuments and street names are
being removed
odessa's statue of Russian Empress
Catherine the Great was recently torn
down we found it replaced with the
Ukrainian flag and many including her
son's Art Museum director who used to
speak Russian have stopped
I felt like I was dying the Russians put
our paintings inside a filthy truck like
garbage she says speaking Ukrainian we
are going to get them back paintings and
artifacts can be stolen but Vladimir
Putin is discovering this country's
cultural heritage is not so easily
erased Jeff Semple Global News her son